and today as you have witnessed all the  games creating best gaming experiences  actually are gathering here we want all  players to come here gather and help  ultimate gaming experience with ps4  those who have loved playing games in  the past but are not playing anymore and  those who never had the chance to play  console games that want to experience  dynamic and rich games with consoles in  order for everyone to be able to enjoy  ps4 with this belief in mind and with  the soap in mind we have decided to  reset the price of ps4 into the new  price of thirty 4998 een this will  become available in the japanese market  starting october first with this new and  more affordable price we hope to provide  an opportunity for those users who have  not yet experienced this device to dive  into the world of PlayStation 4